closest race in the 2020 election is now
official
democrat ross miller will take clark
county commission district c
seat the margin just 10 votes the
i-team's david charns here live in
studio to tell us
why it took so long to get here david
well brian you may remember when we told
you just two weeks ago the commission
decided to certify
every other race in clark county except
this one and this is why take a look
just 10 votes
yeah 10 votes separating democrat ross
miller from republican stavros anthony
10 out of more than 150 000
cast election officials had cautioned
against certifying this vote because the
number of discrepancies was larger than
that margin between the two candidates
now discrepancies we've been talking
about for a couple weeks now that when a
person signs
in to vote but fails to cast one a judge
ruled just yesterday a re-vote for
district c
wouldn't change those tight results and
today the commission decided to reverse
course and not hold a special election
instead certifying miller as the winner
over 150 000 people voted in this
contest
it's very out of the ordinary for a a
race with that many votes to be decided
by
ten that margin of victory is very
difficult to reconcile no matter what
the race is with 215 precincts in it
registrar voters joe gloria there saying
in the four weeks now since election day
his office has received hundreds of
phone calls from people who received
false information
about their votes not being counted now
if anthony had won this race he would
have been the first republican
commissioner to sit on the commission in
more than a decade
and though the race is now certified
these court cases can continue
though a new election is extremely
unlikely
i'm david charns 8 news now david thank
you coming up